Uncle Máximo!
Hugo!
I've decided to tell you my life story.
It all starts in Acapulco.
This was the deciding moment in my life.
For a poor kid
from the streets of Acapulco,
the way to a better life
was a job at Las Colinas,
the most glamorous resort of all.
I'm Diane, the owner of Las Colinas.
Welcome to our hotel.
Promise me you're
not gonna let that place change you.
I can't believe I'm sitting here.
I can't believe I'm sitting anywhere.
My family just has the one chair.
This is where all the action is.
One mistake, and your career here
will be over. Good luck, papi.
So I just served filet mignon
to a dog. Is that normal here?
More normal than you'd think.
Máximo, if you wanna keep this job,
maybe don't hit on the boss's girlfriend.
I had this idea of what
it'd be like working at a place like this.
But I'm not sure I feel comfortable here.
I know that whatever happens there,
you're only doing it
so we can have a better life.
Every dream has its price.
Are you willing to risk it?
You come home
super late at night smelling like shame.
I already told you that smell is chlorine.
My mother was afraid
the resort would change me. But maybe...
it would be the other way around.
No more dreaming, Memo.
From here on out,
we're making our dreams come true.